vamos a tratar de ponerle nombre a esta
molécula y por supuesto como siempre
hemos estado haciendo primero tenemos
que encontrar cuál es la cadena de
carbonos más larga que se está
justamente que estoy poniendo con
amarillo y que tiene 7 carbonos verdad
lo siguiente es poder enumerar lo de tal
suerte que los sustituyen t se
encuentren digamos en el número más bajo
de esa denominación entonces aquí da
igual si empezamos de izquierda a
derecha porque en cualquier caso estará
en el cuarto carbono verdad si empiezas
de aquí hacia acá verás que coincide con
el cuarto ahora bien tenemos este
sustituye ente de aquí que por supuesto
tiene tres átomos de carbono verdad
tiene 1 2 3 pero este sustituye ente no
tiene la misma estructura lineal que
hemos estado trabajando en los otros
casos es un poco raro verdad así que
tenemos que preguntarnos cómo asignarle
un nombre y eso es lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo por supuesto este tendrá
como nombre principal digamos
verdad porque tiene una cadena principal
de 7 carbonos ahora bien aquí tengo este
grupo sustituye ente que tenemos aquí
arriba y voy a poner digamos este
zig-zag para para indicar que esto está
conectado a una a una cadena mucho más
larga verdad entonces como ponemos el
nombre a esta a esta molécula y pues o
más bien en este sustituye ente pues
vamos a tener que hacer exactamente lo
mismo que hacemos con los arcanos
tradicionales tenemos que encontrar
nuestra cadena más larga que sería ésta
partiendo de la conexión verdad aquí
tenemos el 1 y el 2 verdad ponemos aquí
el 1 pues porque queremos el digamos que
él
queremos el número más bajo posible
entonces aquí tenemos digamos como un
grupo estilo mientras que aquí también
tenemos un grupo metilo entonces como le
llamaríamos a este pues seguimos las
mismas reglas verdad tenemos aquí un
estilo aunque sería algo así como útil
pero tenemos un grupo metilo unido en el
carbono primero entonces sería un uno
metil etil verdad este es un grupo uno
metil etil y esto es digamos la
nomenclatura que se le asocia con más
bien que la iupac le ha asociado a este
digamos a este sustituye ente pero
también éste tiene un nombre común
verdad este tiene un nombre común y se
le conoce como hizo propio este es un
piso propio y él hizo pues yo más bien
creo que es porque si pensamos en este
primer carbono tiene 22 a 22
ramificaciones digamos los grupos metilo
unidos así que se ven digamos
esencialmente iguales y de ahí quizás el
prefijo
pero este es el nombre común verdad esto
generalmente lo vamos a ver cuando
tengamos este tipo de estructuras en
jeff ahora estos dos son correctos tanto
podemos utilizar la nomenclatura que
asigna iupac o la nomenclatura digamos
común para este para este sustituyen t
entonces cómo quedaría el nombre de esta
de esta molécula completa pues vamos a
tener un uno metil etil metil etil esto
es digamos un sustituye ente que está
unido al eta no pero no en cualquier
lugar sino en el cuarto carbono entonces
éste sería un 4-1 metil etil eta no el
nombre común serio o más bien utilizando
la nomenclatura común sería un 4 hizo
propio hizo propio eta no muy bien
entonces estas son las dos formas de
asignarle el nombre
o darle asignarle un nombre a esta
molécula vamos a ver otros dos ejemplos
o más bien deberíamos revisar los
distintos sustituye o perdón sustituye
entes que podemos tener con cuatro
átomos de carbono entonces para para
pensar que estos son sustituye entes
vamos a poner que están unidos a una
cadena principal a una cadena más larga
de esta forma como lo hicimos en el
ejemplo anterior entonces ahora lo que
tenemos que ver aquí es exactamente lo
mismo para identificar o más bien para
asignarle un nombre a esta a esta
molécula tenemos o más bien a este
sustituye ente tenemos que encontrar la
cadena más larga que es justamente ésta
y enumerar lo de tal suerte que quede el
número más bajo verdad entonces tenemos
esta enumeración y ya podemos asignarle
un nombre al sustituye ente porque
tenemos tres a una cadena d
perdón decía que teníamos una cadena de
tres átomos de carbono entonces esto le
asignaría un nombre como de propia
verdad porque esto es un grupo alquiló
entonces sería algo como propio pero
tenemos un grupo metilo que se está
uniendo en el primer carbono entonces
tendríamos un uno metil propio verdad
entonces éste sería la nomenclatura
digamos este que asigna iupac pero esto
también tiene un nombre común y se le
conoce como sec útil que esto es el ser
útil vamos a pasarnos con este ejemplo
aquí encontramos nuevamente la cadena
más larga y ahí la tienen son tres
átomos de carbono verdad 1 2 3 y pues
eso significa que va a tener un nombre
como de propiedad pero ahora lo que
tenemos es un grupo metilo en el segundo
carbono entonces esto sería algo así
como 2
mi til propia verdad este es un 2000
propio y este también tiene un nombre
común y se conoce como hizo útil y otra
vez pues aquí podemos ver que a partir
del carbono 2 tenemos una dos
ramificaciones en grupos metilo verdad
se ve como esta estructura de jett por
eso es digamos yo creo el nombre de
isobutilo verdad ok entonces vamos con
el último ejemplo nuevamente encontramos
nuestra cadena más larga a partir de
este y pues podemos ver que sólo que
queda lo mismo cuando agarramos verdad
nuestra cadena más larga es de dos
átomos de carbono entonces esto sería
algo así como un reptil grupo de tilos
que en el primer carbono se están
uniendo dos grupos metilo entonces eso
quiere decir que tenemos dos grupos en
metido eso sería un y metil etil pero
ambos están en el carbono 1 verdad
entonces éste sería un 11 dimetil
sería 11 de metil etil y verdad y su
nombre común es el ser útil ser útil que
yo en algunos lados he encontrado que
omiten este este guión vamos a ponerlo
en este caso así que ahí están las tres
posibilidades para un sustituye ente con
un total de cuatro carbonos vamos a ver
otras posibilidades ahora vamos a
fijarnos en por ejemplo estos de aquí
que tienen cinco carbonos y que son los
más comunes entonces vamos a poner que
éstos están unidos a cierta estructura
lineal más grande y vamos a encontrar
primero la cadena más larga entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 aquí hay cuatro átomos
de carbono 1 2 3 4 pero en el tercer
carbono estamos uniendo un grupo metilo
entonces tenemos un propio un propio
donde en el tercer carbono se une un
metil entonces tenemos un metal en el
tercer carbono esto sería el 3
el propio o que también se le conoce
como is open till it's open til i spent
ir pues porque tenemos justamente 5
carbonos verdad pero este prefijo hizo
pues es justamente por nuestra
estructura en ye y esto también a veces
se le conoce como hizo a mil que hizo un
grupo y su amigo o simplemente hizo a
mil muy bien vamos con el otro ejemplo
aquí tenemos 123 tendremos tres átomos
de carbono una una cadena con tres
átomos de carbono eso nos da un un
propio verdad no
perdón acá me equivoqué aquí en realidad
cuando tenemos cuatro es un bucle verdad
entonces aquí no es propio esto es un
útil
a corregirlo
fútil o que quizás debería corregir lo
mejor si verdad porque tenemos una
cadena de cuatro átomos de carbono
entonces cuando tenemos cuatro átomos de
carbono tenemos wood y los entonces este
es un metal útil y ahora si este si es
un propio un propio que en el segundo
carbono estamos uniendo dos grupos
metilo entonces esos serían un dimetil
dimetil que se unen en el carbono dos
ambos entonces éste sería un 22 dimetil
propio y su nombre común es el cne open
till otra vez spend il pues porque
tenemos justamente 5 átomos de carbono
muy bien ahora vamos ya tenemos ahí
varios ejemplos de como asignarle nombre
a los a los grupos sustituye entes vamos
a verlo con un ejemplo en particular
en este ejemplo en particular verdad y
esto bueno pues tenemos que ubicar
primero nuestra cadena o nuestro ciclo
más largo entonces si nos damos cuenta
nuestro ciclo tiene cuatro átomos de
carbono y si omitimos el ciclo podemos
ver que esta cadena tiene cuatro átomos
de carbono también y vimos en el vídeo
anterior que cuando tenemos un empate
entre las dos estructuras pues siempre
nos vamos con el el arreglo cíclico
verdad nos vamos con el arreglo cíclico
y entonces quién gana es el ciclo butano
ciclo bután muy bien butano pues porque
tiene cuatro átomos de carbono ahora
vamos a tratar de darle un nombre a esta
a este grupo sustituye ente entonces qué
es lo que tenemos tenemos que hallar
digamos de este punto la cadena más
larga que en este caso es ésta y tiene
tres átomos de carbono 1 2 y 3 entonces
esto sería un propio proyectil que se le
está añadiendo un grupo metilo en el
primer carbono entonces esto sería un
metil propio añadido en el primer
carbono verdad y todo esto lo encerramos
entre paréntesis para decir que es un
grupo sustituye ente que se une al ciclo
butano ahora hay que decir también en
qué punto se une al ciclo butano y aquí
en realidad se puede omitir porque está
implícito pero si uno quiere ser más
explícito puede no poner que está en el
primer carbono del ciclo de cuatro
átomos de carbono que es el ciclo butano
verdad entonces ahí
la nomenclatura también podríamos
utilizar el nombre común y recordemos
que el uno metil propio el uno metil
propio y también es ser útil ser útil
entonces esto también podría llamarse
ser útil
útil ciclo butano ciclo butano muy bien
entonces ahí lo tienen
vamos a trabajar ahora un poquito con
algo que conocemos como la clasificación
de carbonos ok entonces vamos a irnos un
poco más abajo esto vamos a trabajar con
la clasificación clasificación de
carbonos y esto esencialmente sólo tiene
que ver con cuántos otros carbonos está
unido un carbono en particular así que
por ejemplo si partimos de un carbono
que está unido a otros tres hidrógenos
digamos que estos son tres hidrógenos y
digamos que de un lado está unido a un
grupo sustituye ente al que tiene ahí un
carbono entonces vamos a decir que este
carbono de aquí va a ser primario va a
ser primario y simplemente pues porque
está unido a un único carbono si
nosotros tuviéramos este mismo carbono
digamos pero
digamos de gmail déjenme cambiarlo
tenemos este
tenemos ese mismo carbono pero ahora
está unido sólo a dos hidrógenos digamos
que está unido a este hidrógeno y este
otro hidrógeno y digamos que aquí está
unido un grupo a un grupo funcional oa
un grupo sustituye ente y acá arriba
también y le pongo ere prima para
diferenciarlo de este otro podrían ser
distintos verdad en este caso nuestro
carbono está unido a dos otros carbono
cada uno de este grupo sustituye ente y
por eso se le conoce como un carbono
secundario secundario ahora el siguiente
caso es que tuviéramos este mismo
carbono unido a tres grupos sustituye
entes digamos r r prima
prima es decir estos tres podrían ser
distintos y unido a un un hidrógeno
entonces a este de aquí se le conoce
como terciario
este es un carbono terciario y el último
caso es cuando este mismo carbono está
unido a cuatro grupos sustituye entes
todos podrían ser distintas aquí sería
tri prima entonces a éste
se le conoce como cuaternario este sería
cuaternario muy bien y simplemente
depende de cuántos carbonos están unidos
a este carbono en particular entonces
por ejemplo si nos vamos a los ejemplos
digamos donde teníamos los los wood y
los entonces si nos damos cuenta aquí
tienen un set un set y eso es porque
este primer carbono está unido a dos
otros carbonos verdad bueno es la única
explicación que yo he encontrado no ni
siquiera en los libros pero éste sé que
podría ser porque este primer carbono es
secundario
en cambio este este primer carbono está
unido a otros 3 carbonos que por
supuesto no están en la cadena principal
verdad estamos omitiendo la cadena
principal entonces si omitimos la cadena
principal este primer carbono está unido
a otros 3 carbonos lo cual lo haría en
ese sentido terciario verdad ya lo mejor
por eso es ser útil verdad
entonces ahí esto es realmente sencillo
vamos a ver por ejemplo cómo clasificar
los carbonos de este de este ciclo
butano este por ejemplo de aquí está
unido únicamente a un carbono verdad que
es el este que marcamos como 2 entonces
este es primario en cambio éste está
unido a otros 2 lo cual lo haría un
carbono secundario este de aquí está
unido a 1 2 3 eso lo haría un carbono
terciario mientras que éste solo está
unido a uno lo cual lo haría un carbono
primario este en cambio de aquí los que
ya están en el ciclo sería un carbono
terciario verdad 1 2 y 3 mientras que el
resto de los carbonos que se encuentran
en este ciclo serían secundarios verdad
serían secundarios porque sólo están
unidos a 2 así que nuevamente lo mejor
esto no te parecerá muy relacionado con
el tema pero esto vendrá más adelante en
vídeos futuros y con otros grupos
funcionales